[Music]  this is kimura i'm here to offer you  federal protection i know you're afraid  but you can save me right  i can help you stay alive  congratulations  you've just been erased  we've got the fbi with me we'll take  ourselves i can't let you do that  there's been a breach you know the drill  i know what must be done  let's go grab her  game time  the mason pollard i know would never do  this something very serious must have  happened  bring him in alive  come on we gotta go  greet up  follower blocked mini camino's face her  biometrics and his own from the cctv  network  oh yeah was that tracking him now and  have issued a warrant for his arrest  she needs your help i need your help  we're here for you  oh  you want me  come get me  i got you  [Music]  you